hey youtubers it's Charlie so I had a
chance to see edge of tomorrow earlier
this week which is why I'm posting this
review earlier than I normally do I'm
also gonna be posting a video about
Emily Blunt as Catwoman but I wanted to
post this video first so you'd
understand why I think that might be an
awesome thing because most of you
probably haven't seen the movie yet I'm
just gonna do my non-spoiler review
first and then I'll get into spoilers so
there'll be like a clear warning in the
middle of the video but if you're
finding me for the first time since
we're in the middle of summer movie
season I'm gonna be doing a bunch of big
movie reviews each week you know like
How to Train Your Dragon Fault in Our
Stars guardians of the galaxy so be sure
to subscribe to get everything and feel
free to suggest movies for me to do the
screening that I went to was actually at
Mann's Chinese Theater it was really
cool Tom Cruise showed up at the end and
answered a whole bunch of questions took
a bunch of selfies I posted a bunch of
pictures of that on Twitter and
Instagram if you wanted to see him the
last big sci-fi Tom Cruise movie I saw
was oblivion which looked amazing but
didn't really make me cheer out loud at
the end the director of that movie was
actually the guy that did Tron Legacy
this movie is a whole different team of
people with the addition of Emily Blunt
and Bill Paxton and they made all the
difference
hail Hydra it's like Starship Troopers
meets Groundhog Day meets Kenny from
South Park and what are those things
have in common
yes they're all a little bit science
fiction but they all do comedy really
really well which is one of the first
things I noticed about this movie I
found it really easy to connect with the
characters and the way they play with
the conceit of time in the movie is
really cool too it's on all the posters
lived I repeat
it's like video game logic you know you
try strategy get squished and respawn so
you can try again they don't get so
stuck on explaining how the whole thing
works that it slows the movie down but I
can make like a whole video just about
time travel in this movie because the
way they chose to explain it is actually
pretty fascinating Tom Cruise at that
screening I went to said that he didn't
even think of it as a movie about an
alien attack it's like Bill Murray in
Groundhog Day where the whole movie just
revolves around his perspective as it
changes with each respawn Emily Blunt
ended up becoming one of my number one
female badasses at least in the movies
this summer lady Brienne is always gonna
rule the bear pit on my TV but Blunt
works so well on this time-travel loop
Tom Cruise is the one who changes a lot
each time so
it creates a lot of opportunities to use
those response for comedy and they
definitely take full advantage of that
the way they set her character up is
really awesome too it's like when we
meet Buzz Lightyear for the first time
in that first Toy Story movie you know
her face is on everything and she's just
like the most elite of elite which is
why whenever they use those response for
comedy the jokes are so much funnier I
feel like the humor is what's gonna make
the movie fun to watch more than once
and there aren't a lot of new movies
that I watch more than once now the only
other non spoilery thing that I want to
mention is Bill Paxton this year has
been so good to him first he literally
killed it on agents of shield hail Hydra
but in this movie he gets to be the
character that conveys the entire
narrative like the speech or turn of
phrase that might not seem super
important at first but then later ends
up being what the whole movie was about
so when you go see this movie make sure
you pay special attention to what Bill
Paxton says but he also gets to be super
funny as expected and don't be surprised
if you get like brain flashes of Hudson
from aliens the only thing that I would
have liked to see more of was emily
Blunt's character at least her backstory
we learn a lot about her but because
this is a Tom Cruise movie the vast
majority of the camera time is spent on
him she does get some pretty awesome
scenes though but here's one we need to
talk about my top five moments so we're
gonna be getting into spoilers so
careful if you haven't seen the movie
yet but here we go
number five Tom Cruise I'm
talking about the beginning of the movie
before he's sucked into the time loop
and starts that Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey if you haven't heard about it
it's just a narrative structure that all
major hero stories share in common so
whenever big-budget movies are made they
typically stick to all the different
stages in this picture I would say that
Tom Cruise versus the general
was just funny enough that I didn't hate
his character in the beginning but
watching him get his ass handed to him
and that first time Luke was a lot of
fun number four the really funny way
they edited all the responds I'd loved
the way they were just hard cut to make
things funnier they really only use that
kind of cut each time he dies each new
time the slam to him waking up on the
palette was just a little bit funnier so
usually the editing isn't something
you're supposed to notice like if an
editor is really good you don't really
notice the transitions between scenes so
I really feel like they did a good job
of subverting that in this movie for
appropriate use of comedy
three buzz lightyear Emily Blunt just to
be clear buzz lightyear is funny because
he's kind of an idiot I'm talking about
that very first time we as the audience
meet her her face is on all the
billboards and the newscasters are
talking about her like she's the second
coming of Jesus and the army has even
made her their public face she's like
the biggest badass ever and even when
Tom Cruise turns into a badass later in
the movie he's still not as good as
Emily Blunt so I feel like it's some
vindication for her at least as an
actress because she's been up for a lot
of big big action roles and it just
hasn't worked out but I'll talk more
about that whenever I do my Batman vs
Superman video tonight just to give you
a little tease though originally she was
supposed to be Black Widow and Iron Man
2 and Catwoman and Christopher Nolan's
Dark Knight Returns it ended up just not
working out but finally she kind of gets
to be that Buzz Lightyear super badass
character you know - the part about him
being an idiot and number two
Tom Cruise becomes badass Tom
Cruise the hero montage was just as much
fun as all the funny montages and a lot
of times those two things became the
same thing like when Emily Blunt was
constantly forcing response by shooting
him in the head I think my favorite
badass time loop was the last one they
did on the beach whenever he's doing
cartwheels and jumping around Bill
Paxton and the other J company people
and they just sit there with their jaws
in the sand what was that guy's name
again but my number one moment from the
movie Tom Cruise becomes Kenny from
South Park they don't ever explicitly
say how many times he's died but Emily
Blunt only made it to about 300 so I
think he died way more times it's really
not till after about the first 30
minutes of the movie that he turns into
Kenny from South Park and you start
laughing at each of those responds each
time he dies that's really what's gonna
make this movie so much fun to watch
again for example Groundhog Day is one
of the most replayed movies on
television anywhere in the world that
movies great for a lot of other reasons
but I'm such a nerd for comedy that I
always get really excited when a science
fiction movie that's as dark as this can
make me laugh a lot but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments below
what was your favorite part of the movie
you know was it all the response or was
it one of the characters I would say my
biggest question after I walked away
from the movie was explaining what the
time-travel situation is after the Omega
is dead like earlier he got the Alpha
blood and was able to control resets for
that
very specific time point then at the end
he got the omega blood and was able to
go back even further in time I think the
explanation is is the Omega was like the
time machine and the blood was like the
key that activated it so now that the
Omega is dead Tom Cruise cannot respond
anymore before they explained all the
time-travel stuff I actually thought
that someone was spying for the aliens
so it was a big surprise and I'm really
glad that they did it the way they did
but as I mentioned earlier Emily Blunt
has been up for a ton of big action
roles and it just hasn't worked out in
the past now she's up for Catwoman in
the new Zack Snyder Batman vs. Superman
movie so I'm gonna be doing that video
tonight kind of explaining how that's
gonna work be sure to subscribe to get
it
I'm also seeing Fault in Our Stars
tonight so that video will probably post
on Friday but right now click here to
get my big Star Wars Episode seven
update and click here for my Maleficent
review
spoiler alert Angelina Jolie was amazing
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight